HOW MANY PEOPLE WOULD I NEED TO GET TOGETHER,
TO REGISTER A SMALL EARTHQUAKE OF MY OWN?
HI.
I’M TIM AND THIS IS SCIENCE?
THE SHOW WHERE WE MAKE SCIENCE SO EASY TO
UNDERSTAND, IT COULDN’T POSSIBLY BE ACCURATE.
IT SEEMS LIKE EVERYBODY HAS WORLD CUP FEVER.
AND WE CAN’T BLAME THIS PANDEMIC ON CELEBRITY
ANTI-VAXXERS LIKE ROB SCHNEIDER AND JENNY
MCCARTHY.
THIS TIME.
IT’S BECAUSE SOCCER —OR “FOOTBALL”—
IS SO DAMN EXCITING.
DURING A MATCH BETWEEN MEXICO AND GERMANY,
ONE GOAL, IN PARTICULAR, LEFT SO MANY MEXICANS
JUMPING FOR JOY THAT SEISMIC SENSORS PICKED
UP A SMALL EARTHQUAKE.
UN POQUITO EARTHQUAKE-O.
THAT GOT ME TO WONDERING, HOW MANY PEOPLE
WOULD I NEED TO GET TOGETHER TO REGISTER A
SMALL EARTHQUAKE OF MY OWN. AND I DECIDED
TO FIGURE IT OUT IN AN EXPERIMENT I LIKE TO
CALL…
BEFORE I COULD GET ALL MY FRIENDS TOGETHER
I HAD TO FIND OUT “WHAT THE HELL IS AN EARTHQUAKE?”
SO I GOOGLED THAT SHIT.
THAT SEARCH LEAD ME DOWN A YOUTUBE RABBIT
HOLE OF VINTAGE STANDUP CLIPS FROM A COMEDIAN
CALLED EARTHQUAKE.
HE’S REALLY FUNNY.
HIGHLY RECOMMEND.
AFTER THAT I FOUND OUT THAT EARTHQUAKES ARE
USUALLY CAUSED BY A SUDDEN RELEASE OF ENERGY
IN THE EARTH’S LITHOSPHERE.
WHATEVER THAT IS.
READING THAT GOT ME SLEEPY, BUT THEN I THOUGHT
ABOUT A HILARIOUS JOKE EARTHQUAKE TOLD ON
DEF COMEDY JAM IN 1995.
THAT WOKE ME RIGHT UP.
HEY, PALS.
I’M LOOKING FOR AS MANY PEOPLE AS POSSIBLE
TO MEET UP SO WE CAN MAKE AN EARTHQUAKE.
I’LL GET A CASE OF BEER, SOME CHIPS, AND
DIP AND MORE.
HOPE TO SEE YOU THERE.
AND WE’RE OFF.
ALREADY GOT ONE MAYBE.
LOOKS LIKE PEOPLE ARE PRETTY BUSY THIS WEEK.
MAYBE SOME PERSONAL OUTREACH.
MAYBE CRAIG’S LIST WILL HELP.
NOTHING?!
HOUSTON, WE HAVE SOME INTEREST.
MOST OF THESE EMAILS ARE JUST PENISES.
NOT VERY HELPFUL.
A COUPLE OF PEOPLE TOLD ME TO EAT SHIT.
THAT’S NOT WHAT THIS EPISODE IS ABOUT, BUT
THANKS FOR THE SUGGESTION.
OH, HEY.
ARE YOU BUSY THIS WEEKEND?
YOU WANNA GET TOGETHER FOR AN EXPERIMENT?
ELLIE: I ACTUALLY HAD PLANS THIS WEEKEND BUT
THANKS.
WELL, I HAVE FOURTEEN MAYBES ON FACEBOOK,
SO FIVE OR SIX PEOPLE SHOULD SHOW UP.
LET’S GIVE THIS A SHOT.
ANYBODY WANNA HANG OUT IN THE PARK?
I GOT SOME BEERS.
JUST NEED TO JUMP AROUND A LITTLE BIT.
IT’LL BE FUN.
OH, OK.
SO WHAT DID WE LEARN TODAY?
WE LEARNED THAT PEOPLE WHO ARE YOUR “FRIENDS”
ON FACEBOOK AREN’T ACTUALLY YOUR FRIENDS
AT ALL. AND SOMETIMES PEOPLE GIVE YOU THEIR
PHONE NUMBERS BUT THEY DON’T REALLY WANNA
TALK TO YOU.
OFF CAM: I THOUGHT WE WERE LEARNING ABOUT
EARTHQUAKES?
YEAH.
WELL MAYBE NEXT TIME YOU’LL ANSWER MY TEXT
MESSAGES AND WE CAN, GREG!
UNTIL THEN, I’M TIM AND THIS HAS BEEN SCIENCE!